[Musique]
hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ambiance survoltée hier à deux pas de
beaubourg en plein centre de la capitale
la scène dressée par le département de
la réunion face à son antenne parisienne
donne un air de cabaye créole pour cette
36e édition de la fête de la musique
ragga dance moring au maloya et sega
c'est toute l'âme de la réunion qui fait
vibrer des milliers de visiteurs et vous
donne une énergie insoupçonnée sous une
canicule historique 21 juin les racines
et la transmission de la culture c'est
ce qu'a voulu rappeler la représentante
de l'antenne du département à paris le
département de la réunion
et là on plaisante et des réunionnais et
auprès du public parisien
le maloya c'est l'âme musicale de la
réunion c'est je rappelle que la loya
hérité de nos ancêtres qui transmis de
génération en génération a été inscrit
depuis 2009 au titre du patrimoine
culturel immatériel de l'humanité
certifie par l'unesco et je pense que
c'est important de le dire ce soir parce
que c'est notre héritage culturel qu'on
veut mettre à l'honneur ce soir dès
18h30 les voix s'échauffent en
arrière-scène dans le public c'est le
moment de saïfi
après des rencontres sur scène les
combattants mort et lui prennent le
relais des danseuses malgache désir des
spectateurs et des arbres étaient
motivés c'était chaud avec la chaleur
ils ont quand même bouger fait très
chaud 31 degrés et l'argent tuyaux 36 oh
mon dieu
ouais d'accord le dock salei a dû avant
41° des moments difficiles qu'elle
connaît pas les activités terrain benoit
malgré six quand même bien organiser des
grandes manifestations
représenter la réunion et les super de
one to c
cosmopolite il fait pour le 20 décembre
mais là pour la fête la musique aussi
fait mais trouve les biens il est
vraiment très bien et bon voila moi en
tant qu'artiste moi ma cause pour moi et
peut-être aussi pourront vendre comme
andy bown dalo et sur la scène
voilà nous les comptes en l'air pour
autant de soutien ça aussi pas sonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des sourires éclatants des yeux qui
brillent et dr lointain si proche
le département de la réunion a rempli le
coeur des réunionnais et des parisiens
jusque tard dans la nuit
peut-être une explication aux chaleurs
tropicales de ce premier jour de l'été
[Musique]